[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Well, welcome
to problem session 5 of 6.006.
It's a pleasure to see all
your smiling faces here today.
This week, we're going
to cover some problems
in graph theory related
to depth-first search
and breadth-first search, which
were roughly the topics that I
guess we've covered in
the last couple lectures
and what's going to
be on your homework.
And I believe this is
basically the homework
from last year with
a few revisions,
based on some typos we caught.
Oh, and I caught
a spelling mistake
that I'll bother our
instructor about later.
OK.
So without further
ado, let's get started.
I guess we'll just do them in
order for lack of creativity
here.
The very first problem has
to do with some measurements
on a graph, which is actually
a really interesting one to me.
So it turns out that in
a lot of research in--
for some reason, in
computer science,
there's graph theory
research, and then there's
networks research.
And these are two
different communities
for weird historical
reasons that I don't totally
understand.
But people in the network
science literature
often measure things
like the radius
of the graph and some
other kind of measures
that are trying to tell
you something about, like,
is a graph a long,
spread-out thing,
like a line graph, or something
super compact, like a star?
And so on.
And so this problem
is kind of digging
into the algorithmic
aspects of how
we might compute one
of the measurements
that I believe is fairly
common in that community.
So let's kind of go
through these problems.
As usual, in 6.006, we
like to take actually
relatively straightforward
computational problems
and then dress them up
with a lot of language
to make it annoying
for you guys to parse.
And indeed, this problem
is no exception to that.
So in this problem, we're
given an undirected graph.
And as usual, we
will call him G.
And we define a
particular number
that we're trying to measure
in this problem, right?
So in particular, if
we're given a vertex v,
then we can define something
called the eccentricity of v,
which is the distance to
the farthest-away thing.
So in particular,
we can define--
it's going to be given by
the following, which is
the max over all the possible--
I'll try to make
sure my notation--
oops, I've already--
well, that's OK--
over all the other vertices
of the distance from v to w.
So I'm standing at
a point on a graph.
And now I like
make a loud noise.
And the last person to hear
me, the distance to him
would be the eccentricity
of that vertex.
And so this is some kind of
notion of radius or diameter,
but sort of planted at a point.
And then if we want to learn
a property not of a vertex,
but of the entire graph,
one thing we can do
is define the radius.
And that is given by R
of G is the min over all
of the different vertices,
u, of the eccentricity of u.
OK, so I think this is one
of these definitions that's
really annoying to
parse and think about.
So we should draw a
little bit of a schematic
and see what's going
on here, because
especially as a geometry
professor, this one's
kind of nice, because it
translates directly to what you
might do in metric geometry.
So let's say that I
have a circle here.
And I want the world's
most complicated way
of defining its radius.
So for any given point--
there's a point in a circle.
That's a circle, in
case you were wondering.
You know those
internet contests where
they have people that
just walk up to the board,
and draw perfect
circles, and then leave?
I unfortunately am not
an expert at this matter.
But anyway, so if we
think of a point--
like a circle as some
analog of our graph,
and then I draw a
point, which might
be the analog of a vertex,
then what is the eccentricity?
Well, it's the distance to the
farthest-away point, right?
So for this guy, it might
be the length of this line,
roughly, because
that's the distance
to the farthest-away thing.
So for every different
point that I draw,
each point has its own
farthest-away point
in the circle.
So there's some
positive number that's
assigned to every single
point in this domain.
And if I take the minimum
of that positive number,
where do you think I end up?
AUDIENCE: Center of the circle.
JUSTIN SOLOMON:
That's right, Jason.
I end up in the
center of the circle,
because if I think
about it, the distance
to the farthest-away point
in this domain, one thing you
can convince yourself
is that that's
sort of as small as possible.
So this is what we might
call a min-max problem
in optimization, because
we are minimizing
the maximum distance, yeah?
This also shows
up in game theory,
all kinds of different
places that solve this stuff.
But thankfully, in this
particular problem,
we're not going
to need all that.
OK, so right.
So this homework
problem has two parts.
The first is to give an
algorithm for computing
the radius of a graph.
And then the second one
is to give an algorithm
for approximating the
radius of the graph
really quickly, or more
quickly than the first part.
I actually don't know if
there's a lower bound there.
But come back to that later.
OK, so in part a, we're
given G. And moreover, we're
given one additional piece of
information, which we actually
do need in this problem.
I think it's one of those words
that kind of slips past us when
we read a graph theory problem.
But it's important to
pay attention, of course.
And that is, we're given
G. And it's connected.
I suppose, really, it
should be given connected G.
But that's OK.
Now what we want is to compute
the radius of G in time that
looks like the product
of the vertices,
the number of vertices-- oops--
times the number of edges,
or the number of times
the number of vertices.
Your instructor struggles
to speak and write
at the same time.
But it's a skill
that I'm working on.
And frankly, handwriting is much
easier with this little chalk.
OK.
So essentially-- I used to have
a math professor in college
that used this phrase all
the time that was just
like, it's important
not to think here.
The problem asks you to
compute the radius of a graph.
And in some sense,
there's an algorithm
that just writes itself for
computing the radius, right?
Because the radius is the
min over all the vertices,
of the eccentricity.
The eccentricity is
the max distance.
So what would be the
simplest thing to do here?
Well, in some sense, it would be
to loop over all the vertices,
compute their distance to
all the other vertices,
and take the max for
each one of those
and then the min over all of
the guys in the outer loop.
Since I just said a sentence
that I'm realizing doesn't
parse particularly well, let's
sort of write down what I mean,
which is to say, we're going to
think of there being an outer--
that's why we don't use this
chalk-- an outer for loop,
which is computing this min.
So-- right?
Well, what are we going to do?
We can compute the
shortest path distance
to all of the other w in my
graph, take the max of w--
of distance from v
to all the other w's.
Obviously, we can kind of do
these two at the same time.
And then, if this number is
bigger than my current max,
keep it.
Oh, yikes.
If it's smaller than the current
estimate I have of the radius,
then I keep it.
And if it's not, then
I throw it away, right?
So maybe I initialize
my radius at infinity.
And now let's call this
number, I don't know, little r.
If little r is less
than big R, then just
keep it around, right?
And so if we think
about it, I don't
think it's terribly hard to
prove that this algorithm is
correct, because it's
sort of just taking
our definition of what
the radius of a graph is
and translating it into
a braindead algorithm.
So I think really,
the challenge here
is proving the runtime in
this particular algorithm.
So what does our
runtime look like?
So we have a loop over vertices.
So I kind of incur a
factor of mod v here.
And then, well, our
graph is unweighted.
So one strategy for computing
the shortest path distance
would be breadth-first search.
I think that's
what's in my notes.
Yep.
And in general,
breadth-first search,
if you recall from lecture,
takes mod v plus mod E time.
So the question is, OK, so if I
multiply these things together,
what do I get?
I get O of v times v
plus E, like that, time.
But like, uh-oh.
That's not the time that my
homework problem wanted, right?
Because the homework
problem asks
you to solve this in
just mod v times E time.
And somehow we've
incurred an extra factor.
And now we have to figure
out why this is actually OK,
or we have to fix our algorithm.
But in this case, it turns
out that this runtime
is just inaccurate, OK?
What's our intuition here?
Well, I kind of underlined
it for you here.
Our graph is connected.
And in particular,
there's going to be
a nice property of
connected graphs, which
is that the number of edges
dwarfs the number of vertices
here.
So really, if we have v
plus E, in some sense,
this is going to look like
a constant factor times E
plus another E here.
So this whole thing is going
to be v times E time, yeah?
So let's make that argument
a tiny bit more formal here.
So in particular, we
know that G is connected.
And every vertex--
so in particular,
what can happen here is--
OK, unless my graph consists
of one vertex, which
is a case you could dispose of
pretty quickly, what I can't
have is a graph that looks like
this, like one vertex and then
an edge floating around there.
Everything has to be
connected together--
connected together.
OK, so in particular,
what this means
is that every vertex is adjacent
to at least one edge, again,
except, I guess, technically,
the one vertex case.
But I think we can
convince ourselves
that for any graph
of constant size,
we're not terribly
worried about it, right?
It's just the asymptotics
that matter in this problem.
OK, so if every vertex
is adjacent to one
edge, well-- and remember
that every edge, kind
of by definition of an edge,
is adjacent to two vertices.
Then what we can conclude is
that the number of vertices
is less than or equal to the
number of edges divided by 2.
This is a conservative estimate.
And so in particular,
what does that mean?
It means that v is
big O of E. This
is a case where we have to
be quite careful about big O
being an upper bound, right?
In this case, typically,
v is much less than E--
well, depends how
many edges, like
if you have a really
dense graph or not.
But in this case,
what does that mean?
That means that mod v plus mod
E is really just big O of mod E,
right?
Because this is big O of
mod E plus big O of mod E.
And that means that our problem
really runs in v times E time,
which is what we
wanted in our problem.
Are there any questions from
our audience on part a here?
Cool.
AUDIENCE: I don't
quite understand why--
where you went from
the first statement
to the second statement there.
At least one edge implies v is
less than or equal to E over 2.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, yeah.
So I guess there's sort of two
things that matter here, right?
Every vertex is adjacent
to one edge at most.
And every edge-- yikes.
Every edge is adjacent
to two vertices.
I guess, actually, it's the
second one that matters.
So you can never have a vertex
just floating by itself.
So one way that I can
count my number of vertices
is by looking at
the number of edges
and saying that, well, every
edge can touch exactly two
vertices.
Every vertex has
to touch exactly--
well, at least one edge.
So if you put
those together, you
can convince yourself that
this bound has to be 2.
If you want to be
conservative about it,
you can just get rid of the
divided by 2 here, I guess.
It doesn't really matter.
Any other questions
from our audience?
Cool.
All right, so now, let's
take a look at part b.
So in part b here, they ask us
to basically do some version
of the same thing, right?
They want us to now
approximate the radius.
But we're given a
smaller budget of time.
So now what we want
in number b here
is, compute an R
star such that--
I got yelled at in my
textbook that st should always
be "subject to."
I got an angry review
of the textbook
I wrote because of that,
which was puzzling to me.
But amazon.com is not a
great source of useful data.
But in any event, we
want R star, which
is sandwiched between
the radius of G
and 2 times the radius
of G, like that.
Now, notice-- so in
other words, we want to--
the first thing to notice
is we want to upper
bound the radius of our graph.
And already, this
should suggest to us
how we might solve this problem,
because if we take a look back
at our definition
of radius over here,
notice that the radius
is a min, right?
So what's going to
happen if I returned
epsilon of some other vertex?
Well, it's lower
bounded by the radius,
because the radius is the
smallest possible epsilon
over any vertex.
That make sense?
Now, when I was
doing this problem,
because, you know, I'm the
dumb instructor of the three,
I said, well, OK,
but maybe I need
to be somehow judicious
about what vertex I choose.
Like, well, in some
sense, what this suggests
is that maybe I choose
some other vertex,
and compute its
radius, and return
that as our approximation.
But of course, the problem
wants me to sandwich it
between two values here.
So in addition to
upper bounding R,
I want to be less than 2
times R. In other words,
my approximation is
within a constant factor.
I tried some weird stuff, like
farthest point sampling and so
on.
Then I realized that you
actually don't really
need to do any of that.
One thing you can do is
literally choose any vertex,
return its eccentricity.
And that's actually good enough.
So here's our algorithm.
Let me go back to my notes here.
I don't know why I'm
following my notes, actually.
I could do this off
the top of my head.
But they make me feel
better if I'm looking
at them at the same time.
So in particular, what I'm going
to do is choose u and v. Let me
be clear here--
any u and v. So if I'm
using some data structure
to store all my vertices, I just
take the first one, whatever.
And two, I'm going to return R
star is equal to epsilon of u.
Now, of course, this
isn't really an algorithm.
If you do this on your
homework, you'll lose points.
And the reason is that
I haven't told you
how to compute this value here.
So if you were to write out
your answer for this problem,
of course, you
should tell us that,
like, really, to compute
epsilon, what do I do?
I use breadth-first
search to compute
the shortest path from u
to all the other vertices.
And then I guess I take
the max value here.
OK, so I think you guys
can fill in the details
of the algorithm.
The bigger challenge
is going to be
to prove that this is
actually a good bound, right?
And so, in other words,
what we need to prove here--
I don't know.
Like, there's a claim.
There's a proposition.
There's a theorem,
somewhere on that axis.
I'm going to call
this one a claim.
I'm going to downgrade it.
And that is that the
radius of my graph
is less than or equal to
R star, which is less than
or equal to 2 times
the radius of my graph.
OK, so let's prove this thing.
I'm managing to use all of my
boards on one problem here.
OK, so in particular,
to prove this claim,
I need to prove
two inequalities.
This is like two
homework problems in one.
So let's number those off.
There's 1.
There's 2.
OK, so let's do inequality 1.
I think we can squeeze him
into a relatively small space.
So remember, what is
the radius of my graph?
Well, just by
definition, we know
that it's the min over all
possible u of epsilon of u.
So in particular, what's--
the nice property about
the minimum of something
is that it's less than
everything else or equal.
So this-- maybe
let's call this u0,
just to distinguish between
that and the notation I
have on the left-hand side.
This is less than or
equal to epsilon of u,
because, I don't know,
because min, yeah?
So that actually already--
and of course, this is exactly
what we chose to be our R star.
So our first part of
our proof is done here.
So this is the easy part.
And sometimes,
like, this is sort
of what inspired our algorithm.
So we expect this bound to
be kind of straightforward.
OK, but the other
half of the problem
is a little more tricky.
And actually, there's a
solution in the notes.
And then I decided, just to make
it a little more inaccurate,
to write up my own.
But actually, I have I have
an ulterior motive, which
is I notice in
this class we don't
tend to use a tiny piece
of notation that I like.
So for my convenience in
future problems sessions,
I thought I'd introduce it now.
So we're solving a
minimization problem.
The nice thing is that
in this class, everything
we do is finite.
If you take my
graduate course, that's
not going to be the case.
In fact, actually,
in lecture 2, we're
going to do like
variational calculus.
But in this course,
what does that mean?
That means if I
minimize a function,
there is actually a
vertex in my graph
that achieves that
minimum, right?
This is different than
like, for example, if I--
then I'll shut up.
But if I wanted to minimize--
here's f of x equals 1 over x,
and I ask you for
the minimum value.
Well, it's over all x
greater than or equal to 0.
Well, the minimum value is 0
if I take x off to infinity.
But it never quite crosses 0.
So you're kind of in
this weird universe.
If you remember Jason's lecture,
he talked about infs and sups
as opposed to mins and maxes.
But this can't happen
in our problem,
because when we compute
a min, there's actually
a vertex that achieves it.
And that vertex,
we call arg min.
And so this arg here
stands for argument.
So one thing that I
can do is say, OK.
So remember that my
radius is the min, the min
over all u of epsilon of u.
Then I'm going to define a
vertex, u0, to be the arg
min over u of epsilon of u.
And this is just fancy
notation for saying, give me
the actual vertex that
makes this value as
small as possible, yeah?
The nice thing
about this problem
is that we're not worried yet
about how we make runtime.
So I can construct
this kind of thing
and not worry about how I
actually found it, right?
OK, so let's say
that we did that.
So this is, find me the
vertex that actually gives me
the radius, right?
So in other words,
I find that vertex.
And then I find his or
her farthest-away vertex
and measure the distance.
And that distance is the
radius of my graph, OK?
So let's actually do that.
So in particular, then I can
define a second vertex, v0.
Well, how does the
radius algorithm work?
I find the central
guy, and then I
find the one that's
farthest away.
So we're going to
make him the arg
max over all v in my graph
of the distance starting
at u to any v.
So if I think about my circle--
that's a circle.
Then u0 is like that
center of my circle.
And then v0 is like
that far-away point.
This is a schematic, right?
My circle is really a
graph in this problem.
But I think the
analogy actually works.
OK.
But in reality, my
algorithm was braindead.
I didn't actually compute u0.
I just randomly drew--
sorry, I shouldn't
use that word.
I arbitrarily drew a
vertex, u, and then computed
the farthest-away
distance from that guy.
And of course, what
we have to check
is that that thing is within a
factor of 2 of what I wanted.
So OK.
If I have u, then
I'm additionally
going to define one more
thing called v. And that--
oh boy.
OK, so I'm noticing
I'm saying one thing,
and I'm writing another.
u0 is the center of my graph.
I think I said it.
I just forgot to write it.
And then this v is the
farthest-away guy from him.
So basically, the
subscript 0 here means--
is the platonic ideal of
what I wanted in my problem.
And no subscript is going
to mean the other one.
So now I compute the
farthest-away thing from the u
that I actually chose
in my algorithm.
That's some v bar.
So again, remember, my
algorithm just says, OK,
I'm going to choose
some other point, v,
and then return v's distance
to some farthest-away point--
oh, sorry, choose another--
oh boy.
Choose a point, u, and
return his distance
to some far-away
point, v. I think
I've managed to lose
everybody, knotting together
u's and v's here.
OK, so why'd I introduce
all of this notation?
Because this is what's going
on in this problem, right?
To actually compute
the radius, I
want to find the most central
point, u0, and its distance
its farthest-away thing, v0.
In reality, I arbitrarily
chose the point u.
And I returned u's
distance to some point,
v. And I want to show
that those two things are
within a factor of
2 of each other.
OK, that summary
makes sense even,
if I talked in circles
for a little while.
OK, so let's actually do that.
So remember that the thing that
I'm going to actually return
is R star.
And that is equal to the
distance from u to v now,
because I just made
all these definitions.
And now I get to use
my favorite inequality.
In fact, this is sort
of the only inequality
we know in this class
so far, I think,
which is the triangle
inequality, which
says that, of
course, this is less
than or equal to
the distance from u
to u0 plus the
distance from u0 to v.
So in other words,
this is saying,
the shortest path
from u to v is always
upper bounded from the
length of the shortest
path from u to u0 and
then u0 to v, right?
This is drawing a triangle.
Aha!
But take a look.
What is the actual
radius of my graph?
Well, in my notation,
the radius of my graph
is exactly the
distance from u0 to v0.
And this thing is bigger
than the distance from u0
to anything else, by
definition, for all v, right?
So if I flip this inequality
backward, well, take a look.
This is the distance
from u0 to something.
So I incur two
factors of the radius.
And I get the bound
that I wanted, yeah?
And so this is a slightly
more formal little proof
of exactly the same thing
that's in the homework notes.
OK, so the one thing
that's remaining
is to actually show
that our algorithm runs
in a reasonable amount of time.
So I think they give us
a budget of order E time.
But notice, that argument
is precisely the argument
that we just made right here,
just minus the v factor.
And the v factor just
came from looping over
all the vertices in part a.
So now I think we're
done with problem 1.
As usual, I've wasted too
much time on the easy problem.
All right, any questions
about this one?
Excellent.
Well, now that I've written too
much, let's do the rest of it.
I spent time on this
problem because I like it.
It looks like a
geometry problem.
OK.
So now, let's see.
In problem 2, which I
noticed that this homework is
kind of full of
prototypical 6.006
slash graph theory
problems in general.
Like, they just go down the list
of things that people typically
do in graph theory that
are useful tricks to know.
So I would suggest to the
students in this class,
even if it's pass-fail, look
very closely at this homework
before doing the current one.
I think the ordering works
out that they can do that,
because I think you'll get some
good hints for how to solve
all the current homework.
So you heard it
here first, guys.
OK.
So in problem 2, we're talking
about internet investigation.
So in particular, at MIT has
a bunch of different routers
that are connected by
cables to one another.
And essentially,
what are we given?
We're given a bunch
of different routers.
And we're given the length
of the cable in between them.
And the latency,
unsurprisingly, is
proportional to the
length of the cable.
That, in my abstract
understanding
of how computers work,
kind of makes sense to me.
I'm not sure that's
actually true.
But that's sort of
immaterial for 6.006.
I assume our department
has a networks
class if you're interested
in that kind of thing.
And essentially, what
we're trying to do
is sum up the latency
over all of the routers.
So let's break down a
little bit of notation
here while I continue to
dance all over the room here.
I keep losing my chalk.
I need like a holster.
I feel like that would be
useful for the chalk bucket.
OK.
So now we're going
to do problem 2 here.
So we're given r routers.
And some of them are
marked as entry points.
And now we have a bunch of
bidirectional wires, wi,
each of which has length li.
And that's a positive
integer value here.
And actually, because of this--
so technically, I think a
lot of students in this class
have encountered
weighted graphs before.
But if you think about the
narrative of this course,
I think, for the version
of this homework,
we haven't really encountered
weighted graphs yet.
But a better way of putting
it, rather than psychologically
diagnosing your instructors, is
that what we're going to find
is that there are often problems
that look like they're weighted
graph problems, but
they really aren't.
And this is a nice example
where that's the case.
OK, so we define
latency as follows,
that it's at least
proportional to the shortest
path to an entry point.
And now we have two additional
assumptions that we need,
right?
One is that the total latency,
or at least the latency
of every vertex, which is
the same thing-- latency--
is less than infinity.
What is this really
saying, by the way?
Like, when would the
latency be infinity?
It would only be infinity if I
like took a pair of scissors,
and cut a wire,
and just connected
for the rest of the network.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Every router is
connected to some entry point.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yes, exactly.
Like, there's some path from
every router to some entry
point.
Doesn't necessarily mean the
entire graph is connected,
I guess.
But at least you can always
get to an entry point.
And then, moreover,
and this one's
the real kicker
here, that there's
at most 100r feet of wire.
Incidentally, r
stands for routers.
I had the previous
problem in my head
and was thinking
radius a long time.
So don't be like
your instructor.
And actually read the entire
problem before getting
hung up on it.
But in any event, the thing
that you're trying to do
is to compute the sum
over all of the routers--
I don't know, r, whatever--
of the latency of that router.
OK, so that's our problem here.
Incidentally, this
little goofy exercise
I just did of taking
this paragraph problem
and kind of writing it in bullet
points, I find helps me a lot
when I'm trying to solve
these algorithms problems,
because I think it's really
easy to just get like thrown off
by a wall of text here.
OK, so this problem is
screaming out graph theory.
Like, we're practically
using the terms here.
We are using the terms, right?
Like, we've got nodes that
are kind of like routers.
And maybe edges are
kind of like wires.
But there's a bit of a catch,
which is that your runtime--
at the end of the day, I think
you want order r runtime.
That's where things get
a little funky initially.
And so we have to
think a little bit
carefully about how to do it.
And here's going
to be the trick.
So this is starting to look
like a shortest path problem.
But what would you
maybe not want to do?
Would be to iterate over
every single router,
or every single vertex
and every single router,
and compute the shortest path
between every single pair,
because if you did
that-- oh boy, I'm
confusing my terminology.
There are entry points, which
is the thing that I need
to compute the distance to.
And I need to iterate
over every single router
and compute its distance,
maybe, to all the entry points,
and then take the min,
or something like that.
But if I had a double
for loop, then I'm
probably not going to
get order r time, right?
Because somehow, you expect it
to look like something squared,
or like the product
of two terms.
So we have to be a little
more sneaky than that.
And we're going to use sort
of a canonical trick in graph
theory.
OK, so let's follow the
Toucan Sam approach here.
We're going to follow our
nose and say that, OK, there's
basically a graph that's staring
us in the face in this problem.
But then we're going to have to
make a little bit of an edit,
because we'd like to use the
kind of linear-looking time
search that BFS affords us.
But it looks like we have
edge weights in our graph,
because the wires are
associated to lengths, right?
Different wires have
different sizes.
But we have this
nice fun fact, which
is that the total amount of
wire in our whole universe
is less than 100r.
I guess the units of this
100 are kind of weird, right?
It's like feet per router
or something, but whatever.
OK, so in particular,
I'm going to make a graph
with the node per router.
So like, maybe here's a router.
There's another router.
There's router 1 and router 2.
But since I want to use
the sort of linear time
advantages of
breadth-first search
when I'm computing distances,
I can be a little bit sneaky
about this, which
is to say, instead
of having like 10 feet
of wires, I'm going
to have 10 1-foot wires, yeah?
Except now I'm additionally
going to have little chains.
So here, maybe the length l
1, 2 is equal to 3, right?
So I'm going to put
three edges in between.
So in other words--
and I'm going to
connect them with chains
of li edges for each wire.
Does that make sense?
So essentially, I'm going to
take my weighted graph problem
and make it unweighted by just
like repeating a bunch-- well,
not really repeating,
but chaining together
a bunch of edges so that the
total length of this thing
is equal to the distance
from one router to another.
OK.
One thing we might
as well do is bound
the number of vertices and edges
in our graph when we do that.
So first of all, let's think
about the number of vertices.
And we can be totally lazy
and upper bound this stuff.
It doesn't matter.
Well, for one thing, I
have one node per router.
So we incur one
factor of r there.
And now, notice that we're
kind of laying down cable
one little piece at a
time here in our chains.
And now I always tend to have
a fencepost-style headache
about exactly what the
constant factor is here.
But if we're
conservative about it,
we incur at most a factor of
100r kind of additional edges,
because those are all
the different pieces
that we could lay together.
I think it's actually less than
that because of the endpoints,
but whatever, because r
plus 100 r is big O of r.
So the number of vertices in
my graph here is big O of r.
Similarly, what's
the number of edges?
Well, this is exactly the
amount of cable that's inside
of my network, I believe.
Yep.
So this is exactly 100r.
Well, I guess the way
the problem is written,
it's upper bounded by
100r, but whatever.
So this, again, is big O of r.
This is kind of convenient.
So now we have one
number that rules them
all, which is r, which tells
you both the number of vertices
and the number of edges, up
to a constant factor, right?
So one thing I can
convince myself
is if I do BFS on my
graph, that's sort of OK.
Remember, that's
vertices plus edges time.
But in this case,
those are the same.
OK, so right.
So remember, at
the end of the day,
I'm trying to
compute the latency.
This is like the length of
the shortest path to the entry
point nodes.
So here would be a
braindead algorithm,
which is to say, for all
routers, for all entry points,
compute--
I don't know.
Let's call the router
on i, the entry point j.
I compute distance ij like
using breadth-first search
or something.
And then I take the
min of these values
and add them all
together, right?
So I compute-- for every router,
I look at every possible entry
point.
I compute its distance
to the entry point.
I take the min over
all these things.
And now I add that
to my running sum.
There's a problem
here, which is,
I haven't told you the
relative number of entry points
to the total number of routers.
So at least the way that I've
written this algorithm here,
how much time would this take?
Well, there's two
different for loops.
And in the worst
possible case, at least
in my braindead
algorithm, I don't
notice that if I
am an entry point,
then I don't need to
compute distances.
Well, this would take
order r squared--
whoa, r squared time, right?
At least, right?
Actually, I shouldn't even
write big O. I should write--
what's lower bound?
Oh god, I'm a terrible
algorithms professor.
Omega of r squared time,
because I haven't even
accounted for the amount
of time that it takes
to compute the distance, right?
And this is a
problem, because I've
only given you a budget of
linear time for your algorithm,
right?
So this is frowny face.
I tried drawing the
turd emoji on my notes.
And it really-- it didn't work.
OK, so we need a better trick.
And this is actually one of
these prototypical tricks,
which is to do the following.
So let's construct a graph.
I'm going to draw my
graph in a particular way.
But notice that there's
nothing about my algorithm
that cares about the
way that I drew it.
This is just to
make my life easier,
which is, I'm going
to put all the entry
points on the left
and all the remaining
non-entry-point routers on
the right, because I can.
And so this is what
my graph looks like.
So these are like
my entry points.
Here are my other routers.
My graph doesn't
have to be bipartite.
Like, it could be that
my routers are connected
to each other, whatever.
And then there are some edges
that go from my entry points
to the routers in the graph.
I'm trying to make sure
that my graph is connected.
OK.
And so essentially, what this
problem is asking you to do
is to say, OK, for every
single node in my graph,
I need to compute the distance
to the closest entry point
and then sum all those
things together, right?
That's just the schematic
we could have in mind.
So in some sense,
what we want to do
is think about the
set of entry points
as like one giant node,
because it doesn't matter
which of these guys I choose
for my shortest path to an entry
point.
I just need to find one, yeah?
And so here's the basic trick.
And this is one that appears
all over graph theory, which
is I'm going to introduce one
additional node to my graph.
And I'm going to put him
on the left-hand side.
He's really big, because
he is a supernode, which
is a term of art.
This term shows up a lot.
And I'm going to connect
it to every entry
point in my network of routers.
Does that makes sense, class?
OK.
So here's the kind
of cool thing.
So first of all, for
every entry point,
what's the shortest
path from the entry
point to the supernode?
Well, obviously, it
has length 1, right?
I drew it for you here.
Now, here's the thing.
Let's take the shortest
path from the supernode
to any of the routers
on the right-hand side.
What do I know?
Well, clearly-- like maybe
I choose this guy here.
Well, what is my shortest path?
It goes here and then there.
There's one property
that matters
here, which is that it has to
pass through one of these entry
nodes.
Which one does it
have to pass through?
Shrug.
For shame.
Well, remember, Justin's
favorite inequality
is the triangle inequality.
And what does it say?
It says that if I
compute the shortest
path from the supernode
to any node in my graph,
then every sort of sub-piece
of that shortest path
is also a shortest path.
That sentence was hard to parse.
Let's try that again.
So in particular,
if I have a graph
from the supernode to
some router over here,
well, we've convinced
ourselves it
has to pass through
one of the entry nodes.
Which one does that
have to pass through?
Is it ever something that is
farther than the closest entry
node?
Well, no, because I
could compute a shorter
path in that case by
choosing the closest entry
node and then going
to the supernode.
So this is a complicated way
of saying that essentially,
what we really want is for
every router, the distance
from that router, let's call
it i, to the supernode, s.
Is that quite right?
Is that the distance to
the closest entry point?
AUDIENCE: You went
one more inch too far.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: I went
one inch too far, right?
Because I went to the
closest entry point.
And then I took an
additional edge.
So we want to do minus 1.
OK.
So what does this mean?
Well, that means
that I don't actually
have to have this inner for
loop over all the possible entry
points.
I just need to construct this
new special graph with one
additional node-- notice
that's not going to affect
my runtime--
and compute the shortest
distance from the supernode
to every other node
in my graph, and then
use that as my output, yeah?
So in other words, what is my
algorithm going to look like?
Well, first, I'm going to
construct my graph, right?
So what do I need to do?
If I were to write this
out in my homework,
I would have to
talk about how I've
got these chains of edges
between different pairs
of routers.
In addition to that,
I'm going to make
one additional supernode
and insert an edge
from that to every entry point.
Notice that adding the entry
point here just adds a 1
to the number of
vertices, and at most, I
guess, an r to the
number of edges,
which doesn't affect
asymptotically
the size of either
of these two sets.
So that's a good thing.
Now I'm going to do--
I'm going to use BFS to do a
single-source shortest path
from my supernode to
all other vertices.
And how much time
does this take?
Well, remember that in general,
BFS takes v plus E time.
In this case, v
plus E are both--
look like r.
So this is order r time.
OK.
And then finally, I'm
going to sum over routers
i the value of the distance from
the supernode to the router i,
minus 1 to account for that
additional edge that I added.
OK, and that's the
solution to our problem.
OK, any questions
about number 2 here?
Excellent.
Go team.
OK.
So now let's move
on to problem 3.
Am I-- yeah, we're
about halfway.
OK, so in problem 3--
right.
So we're doing Potry Harter
and three wizard friends.
The number three
here, I believe,
is actually irrelevant,
although like any time
you see a specific
number in a problem,
you should cache that in your
bag of things to remember.
And in this case, that
was a red herring.
Potry Harter and her
three wizard friends
are tasked with searching
around a labyrinth, yeah?
And in particular,
there's some nice things
to know about the labyrinth
and Potry Harter world--
this is really throwing
off my dyslexia here--
which is the following.
Right, so what do we know?
We know that there are
n rooms in my labyrinth
and that each of my rooms
has at most four doors.
So in other words, if I
think of building a graph out
of my rooms, which is
like, I don't think
I'm giving much away
about this problem
by jumping to the
solution a little bit,
what do we know about
the degree of any vertex,
assuming my vertices are
rooms in the labyrinth?
It's at most four.
So that's kind of nice.
OK, right.
And all the doors start closed.
So that seems like a
useful piece of information
to remember.
But we have this kind
of weird thing, which is
that some doors are enchanted.
And apparently, Potry
Harter can open up
certain doors for free, which
are not the intended doors.
And then other ones,
they have to do
the blessing, and
the holy water,
and whatever it is that
happens in this universe,
and then opens up that door.
But that costs them materials
and heartache, right?
And so we want to minimize that.
And so what they're
given is basically a map.
And this includes all
of the different rooms,
how they're connected to one
another, and which of the doors
are enchanted.
And what I want is the
minimum number of doors
that they have to disenchant.
Now, this problem is
like kind of sneaky.
And the reason why is that
there's like the network that's
obvious to build.
And that turns out to be
not quite the right one.
And then you can start
thinking about adding weights
on your graph and
going crazy with that.
But that turns out not to
be the right direction.
And in fact, in
Potry Harter world,
apparently, we're not worried
about their physical fitness.
In other words, shortest
paths are actually
irrelevant in this problem.
Do you see that?
Because let's say that I have
a really complicated, annoying
problem.
So like, maybe I have--
here's my labyrinth.
And we don't even talk
about the entry point,
like where they actually go in.
But just for fiction
purposes, let's say
that they enter my
labyrinth here and that,
just to be annoying, the two
doors that are enchanted--
remember, we could
make a graph where
all the vertices are rooms,
and the edges are doors--
are like at these two endpoints
of the T. So I have a giant T.
And I enter right in the middle.
Now, what is Potry
Harter to do here?
Well, obviously, there's--
since this graph is a tree,
there's only so much
they can do, right?
Maybe they enter here.
They walk over all
the way to the end
to disenchant the
door over here.
And then they turn around
and walk to the other end.
They disenchant that guy, yeah?
And now they can
reach other rooms.
Yeah, because that's their
goal, is to visit every room.
Sorry, I think I
skipped that step.
Now, there's a few
things to notice
about this example,
which make it
a little bit different
from the typical graph
theory thing, which is, once
they disenchant this door,
like they walk over here, and
they open it, well, now they
walk over to this
other room, just to--
you know those gym
exercises where
you run to the other side of
the room, you touch the floor,
and then you run back?
That's kind of what
they did here, right?
They ran to this room.
They tapped that vertex.
And now they want to turn around
and walk to the other side.
They don't pay money again
on their way out, right?
So once they open that
door, it stays open.
And that's actually quite
important, because what it does
is it makes this problem not
look like a traveling salesman
problem, which
wouldn't be so great.
OK, so right.
And moreover, does the
fact that they're-- like,
maybe I subdivide these edges.
I have a bunch of edges here
that are all not enchanted.
Does that matter, like if I had
like five billion edges here?
No, right?
Because they only
ask in this problem
for the minimum number of doors
that you have to disenchant,
yeah?
So it might be the Harry
Harter walks really
far along my graph.
But as long as they don't walk
through an enchanted door,
it costs them nothing.
So what does that mean?
Well, that means that in some
sense, the second that I enter
a room, I might as well
walk to every other room
that it's connected to
through unenchanted doors.
And that doesn't
cost me anything.
So sort of as a policy,
I should do that, right?
I enter a room.
And then I kind of
just search around
and enter every
possible door that I
can that doesn't cost me an
enchantment, because those
are free.
And my goal is to
visit every room, yeah?
OK, so here's going to
be the sneaky trick.
Like, what is that
starting to smell like?
I open a door, and now I want
to explore all the other rooms
that are connected to that one.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
connected component.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yeah, maybe
a connected component.
There's a problem.
Is it connected
component in this graph?
Well, no.
Like, this whole graph is one
giant connected component.
So the sneaky trick is
we're actually going
to remove the enchanted doors.
That was supposed to erase,
and it didn't happen.
But the point is that if we
remove the connected doors,
these are like the
chunks of my map
that I can visit without
incurring any cost.
So if I think of my
graph, maybe there's
a bunch of vertices over here.
And then there's
an enchanted door.
And there's a bunch
of vertices over here,
and then like two more
enchanted doors like that.
And like, what goes on
in here, like if this
is like a giant
triangle or something,
is actually irrelevant, because
once I touch any one of these,
I can now touch all
the rest of them.
So let's suggest an algorithm.
So our first step is that
we construct a graph, G,
where the nodes are the rooms--
are the rooms.
And what should the edges be?
Well, if I'm just trying to find
these little clumps of rooms
that I can visit for free
if I get to any one of them,
then the edges are the
non-enchanted doors.
OK?
And so now, in
step two, I'm going
to compute my connected
components, which
we covered in lecture--
the connected
components of my graph,
G. How much time does that take?
Well, remember that there
are two different algorithms
we mentioned that can do this.
This is full BFS or DFS.
And both of them are going to
take the same amount of time.
What is that time?
AUDIENCE: Linear in
the size of the graph.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Linear
in the size of the graph.
So initially, that
could be problematic,
because I want order n.
Remember, there
are n rooms here.
But thanks to our
degree bound, thanks
to knowing that every room
has at most four doors,
you can convince yourself that
both the number of vertices
and the number of edges
are order n, which
I should probably rush
through, because as usual,
I'm going slowly.
OK.
So now, what do I have?
I have a list of all
the connected components
in my graph.
And each one is
potentially connected
to some other ones
by enchanted doors.
So in some sense, I
could think about--
it's not to say this is the
solution to the problem.
But I could think about
modeling my problem
as making some new graph,
where I put a giant vertex
in every connected component.
And maybe I connect
them by enchanted doors.
And I want a path that touches
every one of these rooms.
But that's not quite
the right way to go.
And this is what catches you
by surprise, because this
starts something scary, right?
If you've heard of the
traveling salesman problem,
it kind of smells like that.
But that's not actually
correct here for two reasons.
One is that once I
open an enchanted door,
I can go back through it.
Like, I can like
hopscotch back and forth
through that door as
many times as I want,
and it doesn't cost me anything.
It only costs me something the
first time I open it, yeah?
And moreover, I didn't
ask you to actually
compute me that path.
If you read the problem
closely, it just
asks for the minimum number
of doors you have to open.
So this is a really
sneaky problem,
because it turns out there's
an additional one line of code
that solves this problem.
That's step three,
which I'm going
to write before steps one and
two, just to keep you confused.
And that is to return this
number of connected components
minus 1.
That seems sneaky.
Why is that?
Well, what's going on
here is the following,
which is that let's say
that I walk along-- remember
that my graph is connected.
So what I know is
that I can always
get from any one connected
component to any other.
And so let's just
take whatever order--
notice that the
problem hasn't actually
asked me how to return
an efficient path.
It just asked me for the minimum
number of doors I have to open.
So all I have to do
is convince myself
there exists a path with this
many doors I have to open.
I don't have to
actually return it.
If I did, it would be mildly
more annoying to think about.
OK.
So my graph is connected.
So one thing that I could
do is make the world's--
well, how do I want to do this?
Well, let's see here.
I guess I could come up
with an ordering that
looks like depth-first
search of my graph.
That should do it.
OK.
So maybe I start at this guy.
I just start at some
arbitrary vertex.
And then I'm going to
do depth-first search,
but rather than
on the full graph,
on this kind of
meta graph, where
I've clumped together rooms
that I can get to with no cost.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to start
walking outward
toward this guy and then
a depth-first search,
backtracking, and
then going back down.
And if you think
about it, remember
that in depth-first search,
I have this property,
I never need to revisit a clump
which I've got to it once.
Well, the total number of
doors that I'm going to open
is exactly the number of
connected components minus 1,
because as soon as I've done
that, my depth-first search is
done here, yeah?
In other words, that's the
number of nodes in my graph.
So if I took--
what would be a better way to--
I'm noticing that in my
head, this was easier
to articulate than in words.
Here would be a way
to do it, would be--
AUDIENCE: Maybe add some more
enchanted doors to the graph?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Maybe add
some more enchanted doors.
Ah, that's true.
Actually, my problem's
a little too easy.
So as long as my depth-first
search backtracks
along the paths
it's already found,
then I'm sort of reaching
out into this tentacle,
and then reaching back, and
then reaching to a new place.
I'll never traverse
an enchanted door
that I don't need to, because
I've already seen the location.
AUDIENCE: So you're
traversing a tree, basically?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yeah.
So I've got a shortest path
tree that's going on here.
Actually, I guess a
breadth-first search
would be a better example.
In fact, here's-- OK,
let's be concrete about it.
I'm sorry.
I should have thought
about this more carefully
than I did at home yesterday.
One thing I could do would
be to compute a shortest path
tree from one vertex in this
graph to all the other ones.
In particular, that gives
me the shortest path.
And I could traverse
that tree to one node,
and then traverse
it all the way back,
and then reverse
it to a new node,
and then traverse it all
the way back, and so on.
This is not an efficient path
from a walking perspective.
But from a door
opening perspective,
it's extremely efficient,
because it's a tree, right?
And remember that
the number of edges
in a spanning tree of
my graph is exactly
the number of vertices
in my graph minus 1,
which is exactly the
property we have here.
Whoo, sweating for
a second there.
OK.
So now, in our remaining
30 minutes here, we've
got two more problems, which
is more than enough time,
especially because
the last problem is
largely combinatorial
and less algorithmic.
So I think it's OK to focus--
maybe talk about that at a
high level and show a fun plot.
OK, so for problem 4, we have
an airline, Purity Atlantic.
That's cute, Jason, really.
And it's owned by
Brichard Ranson.
Did I get that right?
And Purity Atlantic
has a cute sale--
this is not like a
cute angle, I suppose--
which is essentially
the following,
which is that you can
book an itinerary where
you have your home city.
And then you choose, I
believe, three other cities
that you want to visit.
And then Purity Atlantic--
maybe you're on your
honeymoon, and you're
not concerned with price, but
rather, just the efficiency,
because you don't want to spend
your whole time in an airplane.
That's particularly
true this month.
Then what do you want to do?
You want to minimize your total
number of connections, right?
Because as we all
know, in spring 2020,
we don't want to spend very
much time in airports, yeah?
So, right.
So how do we do that?
Well, we make a
website, where you
tell Purity Atlantic
the cities that you want
to visit and your home city.
And they give you back
an efficient itinerary
that minimizes the
number of connections.
OK.
And the question is, how do
you actually do that, right?
How do you compute
the best itinerary
that minimizes the number
of flights you have to take?
So what are our variables?
And sometimes it feels
like the variables
are all the different
permutations of the cities you
could visit, right?
I could go to, I don't know,
Cambridge, Boston, and then
Cambridge in the UK.
Maybe you're doing like
a University thing,
and then, I don't know,
Budapest and some other place.
Or I could do those
in any other order.
And that feels like it
should be factorial,
which would be bad news.
But this is one of
these problems which
I suppose a computer
science theorist might
call fixed parameter tractable.
But that's sort of an
overkill term here.
But essentially, as
long as you ignore
all the factors that make this
problem hard, then it's easy.
A different way to
put it is that, OK,
if I'm only visiting
three cities, what's
the total number of possible
orderings of my three cities?
Class?
So I have city A, B, C. I could
do B, C, A. I could do B, A, C.
AUDIENCE: List them out.
JUSTIN SOLOMON:
Yeah, fine, Jason.
I'll do that.
So this is what we call
direct proof mathematically,
which are other possible
ways to visit three cities.
And now, by my direct proof, I
claim there are no other ways
to visit three cities.
And in particular,
there are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 different orderings of
the cities that I can visit.
Notice that this is a
constant in my problem.
I am not asking you
to make a website that
takes like the
total set of cities
that you want to visit as
a couple and order them.
It's specifically three.
You might also notice that 6 is
3 factorial, which is perhaps
a more efficient way to
get to that same bound.
OK.
So, right.
So there's six different
orderings of the cities.
And in each case, what
am I going to have to do?
I'm going to have to compute
the sum of going from my source
city to the first one, from the
first one to the second one,
from the second one
to the third one,
from the third one back
to the first one, OK?
So what do I need?
Well, I need-- in
some sense, I want
to be conservative
about it, just
the cost of flying from every
city to every other city.
But that's not quite right.
I only need the cost of
flying from every city
that you have specified
as a city you're
interested in to
every other city
that you've specified that
you're interested in, yeah?
OK.
So in particular,
I go to my new one.
So in this problem, we have
c cities and f flights.
OK.
And initially, it
might seem that we
have to compute a ton
of shortest paths.
But like, if I want
to go from Boston,
to Budapest, to London, to--
I'm running out of cities--
Paris, and back to Boston, or
whatever ordering I prefer,
do I need to worry about the
shortest path from Nebraska
to California?
Potentially not.
Like, that could be irrelevant.
The only ones that I care
about are those four cities
that I've identified, OK?
So there's 3 factorial
possible permutations.
And at the end of the day, well,
there's 2 times 4 choose 2.
If you're wondering, this is 12,
or big O of 1 pairs of cities,
meaning that, like--
for itinerary
purposes-- itinerary--
meaning that if I always enter
an airport in one of city A, B,
C, or my hometown, and I always
exit through another one,
so then there's four
possible cities.
I choose them two at a time.
Notice that flights
might not be ordered.
Like, I might be able to get
from one city to another.
But then maybe the airplane
has a connection or something.
So going back is
a different cost.
But totally, there's 2 times
4 choose 2 different pairs
of cities that I could
enter or exit from.
OK.
So now, what am I going to do?
Well, so I can compute the
12 different shortest paths
that matter in my graph.
So when I say shortest
path, what do I mean?
Well, I'm going to
construct a graph, G,
with one vertex per city
and one edge per flight.
And notice the
number of connections
that I need to make,
the minimum number
between any city
than any other city,
is equal to the shortest path--
the length of the shortest
path minus 1, right?
So like, maybe I have--
like, here's Boston.
Here's London.
Here's Paris, B, L, P for short.
Then the length of my
shortest path is 2.
And the number of
connections I have to make
is 1, because I stop
through London, yeah?
So what am I going to do?
Well, for every pair
of cities in this--
oops-- no, that's OK--
in the set of the source
city and the three cities
you want to visit, I'm going
to compute the shortest--
the length of the shortest path.
So this is the minimum
number of connections
I need to get from
any one of these
to any other one in my graph, G.
Well, how much time
does this take?
Well, there's 12 such pairs.
We already argued that.
And how much time does it take
to actually do shortest path,
so using breadth-first search?
AUDIENCE: Linear time
the size of the graph.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Linear
time the size of the graph.
I think Jason actually has
a t-shirt that says that.
Well, in this case,
remember, that's
big O of the number of edges
plus the number of vertices.
But just to make your life
a little more annoying,
the number of vertices
is the number of cities.
And the number of edges is
the number of flights, right?
So this takes 12 times O of c
plus f time, which, of course,
is just O of c plus f time.
Notice, this is
one of these things
where we're being sneaky.
We told you that
you specifically
visit three places.
And that's where this
number 12 came from.
If we'd said that you
wanted to visit m cities,
then this would be a very
different homework problem.
This is one of those
things you got to remember,
where we've given
you a few constants,
and you should use them.
OK.
So now, what can I do?
I can iterate over every
permutation of A, B, C, right?
So this is like saying I go from
my source to city 1, to city 2,
to city 3, back to my source.
I add together and compute the
cost, the cost of that trip.
And remember, cost
in this case is
equal to the minimum
number of connections.
And then I return the minimizer.
So I say, like, is
it cheaper for me
to go Boston, Budapest,
Paris, Boston, Paris,
Budapest, and so on.
So a for loop over
permutations, which
generally is frowned upon.
But in this case,
because we told you
you're visiting
precisely three places,
how many steps are going
to happen in that for loop?
Well, we actually wrote them
all out over here on our board.
It's exactly 3 factorial,
or 6 steps, right?
3 times 2 times 1, which is 6.
OK.
So, right.
So at the end of the
day, this for loop
is going to take, well, order 6
time, which, of course, is just
order 1.
So it doesn't really contribute
to our runtime at all.
And our entire algorithm
runs in c plus f time.
OK, so right.
So this is one of
these problems where
you're really taking
advantage of the constants
that we gave you.
We said you're
visiting three cities.
So use it.
Incidentally, as a
computer science theorist,
if I said you're visiting
exactly 17 cities,
well, what would
be our numbers now?
I mean, it would be 17 factorial
and then like 17 choose 2.
Those are big numbers.
But they're still constants.
So for purposes of this
class, that would be OK.
But the second that I
give it a name, like m,
then I got to think about those
factorial things a little more
carefully.
All right.
So that's this problem.
So the basic trick
here was that,
like, yeah, it looks like
all pairs shortest path.
But it's not quite.
It's all pairs of things
that you're actually
going to travel
between shortest path.
And since that number of pairs
is finite-- it's just 12--
that's an OK thing to do.
OK.
How we doing?
Ah, 15 minutes.
Perfect.
I didn't want to do
the last problem.
And I think I've
managed to get myself
in exactly that position.
OK.
So the very last problem
on this homework,
which, again, this
homework really
follows the prototypical
6.006 breadth-first search,
depth-first search homework.
I feel like they all fall
into a similar pattern.
Again, all these resources
are available to you guys.
You should look at them.
We're not trying
to hide anything.
This problem involves
solving a pocket
cube, which is like a
little mini Rubik's cube,
which is 2 by 2.
And it looks like this.
Ah, there's chalk.
Actually, there we go.
So here's my Rubik's cube.
Looks like a cube, which I'm
having some trouble drawing.
And in particular,
it's 2 by 2, which
makes it a little easier than
your typical Rubik's cube.
And in particular, we're
going to mark some faces.
Sneakily, they used a
little geometry term here,
which is cute.
So here's face f0.
I'm sorry you can't
quite see that.
But the top face is f0, in
case you were wondering.
The left face is f1.
And the front-facing
face here, f2.
Notice that we've
identified these
by like vectors that point
90 degrees out from the face.
These are called normal vectors.
If you want to define
those rigorously,
you can take my
grad level class.
But for a Rubik's cube,
it's not terribly difficult.
But in any event, I can talk
about flipping this Rubik's
cube in a pretty easy
way, which is that I like,
I'm going to fix one
corner of my cube.
So this is like the corner that
I'm holding onto with my hand.
And now I can grab, what?
The top, the side, or
the front of my cube.
And I can rotate it clockwise
or counterclockwise.
And you can convince yourself
those are all the possible ways
that I could sort of mess
with the state of my cube
after fixing one corner.
OK, right.
And so this problem
basically is involving
sort of a very typical trick.
In fact, a lot of the history
of these different search
algorithms-- breadth-first
search, depth-first search, A*,
which I guess we won't
really cover here--
date back to, what,
20 or 30 years ago,
we would have called
artificial intelligence.
These days, that has a
very different meaning.
But back in the day, AI was
all about solving board games,
and Rubik's cubes, and
all these kinds of things,
using algorithms.
And the way that
they would do that
is by searching the different
spaces of configurations.
And so now, if we think
of every face of this cube
as painted with a color, there
are different configurations
of my graph that I get by
flipping the three sides.
So if we think of there
being a vertex for each state
of my cube, where
state here means
like the coloring of every
face on my Rubik's cube,
then there's an
edge for every move.
And in this problem, we
encoded a move as a pair,
j comma s, where
it's saying that I'm
going to rotate face fj, where
j is between, I guess, 0, 1, 2,
in direction s.
And we can just index that as
like plus or minus 1 to kind
of say counterclockwise
or clockwise.
So this is kind of
a cute thing, where
your graph has a
bunch of vertices,
which are all Rubik's cubes.
That's a cube.
And then there are edges if
I can get from one to another
by doing one of these moves.
And this is a nice
abstraction, because if I
want to solve a Rubik's cube
in the most efficient way
possible, one way to do that
is to compute the shortest
path from my current
configuration
to the Platonic
Rubik's cube, where
all the colors are constant on
the different faces of my cube.
And so that's like a sort
of basic identification
that happens all over the
place in search strategies,
where I'm going to think
of every vertex of my graph
as being the state of
some system and every edge
as being a transition
from one to another.
And then paths in this thing
are kind of like different ways
of solving my puzzle, right?
So like a different one
would be, I don't know,
every vertex is a chess board
with the chess pieces scattered
on the chess board.
And every edge is one chess
move by one player or the other.
In that case, you'd have to be
a little careful, because you
want player 1 or player 2 to go
back and forth from each other.
But I'll let you think
about the reduction there.
OK, so right.
This problem, I think
largely, is mostly
just fun combinatorics
rather than algorithms.
But there's a little bit of
algorithms hiding in here.
So they want you to
argue that the number
of distinct configurations
of this Rubik's
cube, this 2-by-2 guy,
is less than 12 million.
This is nice, because 12 million
is a number that computers
can actually cope with.
And so there's a pretty
straightforward argument there.
Right.
So in particular, here's a cube.
How many quarters are in a cube?
AUDIENCE: Eight.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Eight, thanks.
I hid one back here, in
case you were wondering.
So let's say that I fix
a corner of the cube,
like we've done that.
Then every time that I rotate
one of the faces of my cube
clockwise or
counterclockwise, I'm
essentially like taking
one corner of my cube
and like sticking it in
another place, right?
So in all, seven corners
of my cube can move.
And if I'm not
worried about, like--
it could be that some
of these permutations
are not actually achievable
by a set of steps.
Like, maybe I'd have to
break my Rubik's cube
and glue it back together.
But if I'm being
conservative about it,
there's of course less
than or equal to 7
factorial different
configurations of the corners.
So in other words, every
time I rotate my face,
one of the corners ends
up in a different place.
So there's 7 factorial different
ways that could have happened.
OK, so that's part of my bound.
Remember that I'm trying
to bound the total number
of configurations here.
And essentially, what I've
done so far is I've said,
OK, well, there's
a bunch of cubes
in my 2-by-2 Rubik's cube.
So I'm going to like
unglue this entire cube,
take just this corner,
and stick it up here.
And there's like 7
factorial different ways
that I could do that.
But I still have to
account for the fact
that I pull this piece off.
I stick it in the top.
But I have to figure
out its orientation.
I can still rotate
it about this corner.
And in fact, there are
three different ways
that I could rotate it, right?
You can kind of see it, right?
1, 2, 3, yeah?
So in all, so each corner
can rotate three ways.
So that means that I
have 3 times 7 factorial
different configurations
as an upper bound.
And this number is,
wait for it, 11,022,480.
The problem asks you to argue
that your upper bound is
upper bounded by 12 million.
And indeed, it is less than
or equal to 12 million.
AUDIENCE: Is that 3
times 7 factorial or--
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, I'm sorry.
Right, because there are
seven corners, each of which
can rotate three different ways.
It's actually 3 to the 7th
power times 7 factorial.
Thank you, student.
OK, right.
So let's see here.
Really quickly moving here,
the next problem says,
state the maximum
and minimum degree
of any vertex in my graph.
First of all, do
I expect vertices
to have different degrees?
This is kind of a goofy problem.
Like, what would it mean to have
a vertex that somehow has lower
degree than another vertex?
It would mean that
there's some configuration
of this cube for which
there are fewer moves that I
could do to change it than
a different configuration
of this cube.
And that's obviously
not the case, right?
Because when I flip one of the
faces of my cube, all I'm doing
is I'm moving the colors around.
I haven't somehow changed
the physics of how
a Rubik's cube works, right?
And so I think this
was just intended to be
annoying by your instructors.
The min degree is equal
to the max degree.
And in fact, the degree
of every node in my graph
is constant here.
The one thing that's
worth noting here--
what I haven't argued--
it turns out, I
think, to be true.
But what I have argued is
that I couldn't rotate a face
and actually end up in
the same configuration.
Like, maybe, for some
reason, I had red all the way
around the outside.
And so when I rotate
it, nothing changed.
That obviously isn't true.
But I haven't
argued it carefully.
But as long as I don't worry
about my graph being simple,
like I'm OK with self-loops,
then the degree is certainly
constant, yeah?
OK.
And in fact, I don't think that
can happen in a typical Rubik's
cube.
AUDIENCE: Well,
I think the point
is to say what the degree was.
JUSTIN SOLOMON:
Oh, yeah, indeed.
So we haven't
computed the degree.
But we've argued that
they're equal to one another.
OK, so now we have to
compute what that degree is.
And here's how to do it.
So of course--
well, this, I think,
is actually even easier
than the first part.
Essentially, remember, we
have three different options
for faces that I can rotate.
I can rotate the top, the
front, or the side here.
So there's three faces
that we could rotate.
OK, and how many different
ways can rotate them?
I can rotate them
counterclockwise or clockwise.
So there's two directions.
So in all, there's degree
6 for every vertex, right?
There's sis different ways
in or out of a vertex here.
OK, so the next
part of the problem
gives you a piece of code and
then does breadth-first search
on this graph.
And it's super,
super slow to give me
the distance to all the
other configurations.
And Jason conveniently has
run it on his laptop here.
I don't-- I'm nervous
to touch your laptop.
I don't care so
much, but I don't--
you know, I don't
want to infect your--
yeah.
Right.
So we have a piece
of code that explores
the graph of all the
configurations of our cube
by breadth-first search and then
sort of gives me the shortest
path, I think from
the base cube,
where all the faces
are constant to all
the other configurations
that are reachable,
and generates a plot.
Right.
And so what they
ask is to figure out
the total number
of configurations
that it explores.
One thing that you'll find out--
center down-- is that it
explores pretty much a third--
in fact, exactly a third of
all the possible configurations
of my cube.
I think we can see that here.
So I guess it runs
this whole thing.
You saw them all together.
Right.
Oops.
That's OK.
And so in fact, the kind of fun
fact that you can learn about
the 2-by-2-by-2 Rubik's cube
is that there's actually three
connected components
in this graph.
So in other words,
there's sort of like three
different Rubik's cubes you can
make, modulo all the different
flips that you can
do to the faces.
And those correspond to
there corner rotations of one
of the corners of the thing.
OK, so right.
So then the next
part of the problem
asks you to state the maximum
number of moves needed
to solve any Rubik's cube.
And you can see it in this plot.
So what this plot is
showing you is the size
of the level set
of this distance
function for every distance.
So I think technically,
it looks like 0.
But there's actually,
this is at a 1
here, which is to say there's
one vertex at distance 0, which
is the source.
And as we move farther
and farther out,
our tree is expanding.
And we're seeing more
and more vertices.
And apparently, most vertices
are approximately distance--
is that 11 or 12?
11 away from the original.
Then eventually I explore the
entire graph, and I'm done.
And you can see that the
farthest-away vertex is 14
away, meaning that the most
annoying Rubik's cube to solve
can be solved in 14 steps for
the 2-by-2-by-2 pocket cube.
I'm sure that Jason probably
knows the equivalent of this
number for the 3-by-3-by-3.
But I have no idea what it is.
I'm impressed if he can
calculate it in his head,
like he looked like
he was about to try.
But I digress.
Right.
So in other words, this is
actually a fancy term for--
we talked about the
radius of your graph
in the first problem.
Now we've got the
diameter, which is, well,
not necessarily 2
times the radius,
the way that we've defined it
here, but actually, almost--
I think within some
constant of that.
OK, so right.
So notice that the vertical
axis here is really big.
And this is explaining why this
BFS code is so slow, right?
Because these are all the
different configurations
it has to hit.
Or more accurately, if
I take the y-position
of each one of these vertices
and sum up its height,
those are all the configurations
that are reachable.
And those are all the steps
that BFS needs before it's done.
And so that number is in the--
it's certainly in
the millions, yeah.
OK, so then the last
part of this problem,
which it conveniently looks
like I'm low on time to solve,
but I'll refer you to
the solution anyway,
is asking how we
might do this faster.
And so in particular,
what it says is,
let's say that I have a total of
n configurations for my Rubik's
cube.
In this case, it
turns out that that's
like roughly three
million, I think.
OK.
And now I want an
algorithm that gives me
the shortest sequence of moves
to solve any pocket cube.
Man, I'm really ravaging
the chalk today.
And I want to solve any
cube in a number of steps
that looks like 2N to the
ceiling of w over 2, where--
let's see here.
The code provided--
sorry, this problem
changed on me this afternoon.
[LAUGHS] Right.
So where N sub i is equal to
the number of configurations
reachable within i moves.
Oh, good.
I see what we did here.
So if this is my base cube,
then we've got like maybe,
I guess, six different--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 different cubes
that I can reach from those.
And then there's 6 cubes I
can reach from all of those.
But of course, some of
those might be pointing
backward or to each other.
But this is the number of things
that are reachable in i moves.
And they ask for an algorithm
that finds the shortest
path in this amount of time.
By the way, big N typically
exponentiates in that subscript
there.
This looks innocent,
but it's not.
The basic trick here is to do--
I'm not going to
bother writing it down.
We'll just talk about it for a
second and call it for the day.
Well, I'll draw a picture.
So the breadth-first
search algorithm
that we've thought about
so far chooses a vertex
and then computes level sets
outward from that vertex
until it maybe reaches
the destination that you
want to hit.
That doesn't quite work here.
And the-- well, I
mean, it does work.
But it's going to be
quite slow, because like,
let's say I had bad luck, and
now we're in that 14 vertex,
right?
Then, somewhere in
there, I'm going
to hit this big height,
which is sitting over the 11,
before I can get to vertex 14.
So the trick here
is it turns out
that I can do it by
only ever getting to 7.
And the way that I'm going
to do that is instead,
I'm going to run BFS sort
of in parallel for two
different vertices, right?
The source and the target.
So in this case, my
current cube and the cube
I would like it to be, like
the solution to the problem.
I'm first going to compute
the level set 1 of that cube,
then level set 1 of the
next cube, then level set 2,
level set 2, 3, 4.
And notice that
eventually, they're
going to intersect, pretty
much right at the midpoint.
And so the size
of the level set--
I never need to compute
a level set that's
bigger than a half of
the shortest path length.
I have to round up to be
conservative about that.
And that's where I
get this factor here.
So that's just a
nice little trick
for reducing the search size.
This is another kind
of standard trick
if you look at some
of the code people use
for solving board games
algorithmically and so on.
I think they typically sort
of search from the beginning
and end state outward and
try and meet in the middle
for exactly this
reason, which is
that exponential
growth, as we all know,
can be quite problematic.
All right, folks.
So I think we're just
about out of time.
And I've certainly
worn myself out.
So with that, hopefully
we'll see you next week.
And yeah, I hope
everybody is doing well.